hey brady
good morning
finally made it in christchurch new
zealand
pretty tired after four hours of sleep
i finally got a gopro
what do you mean you knew
um yeah
so cool anyway i'll be able to film on
the ice it was pretty epic bringing our
11 boxes through
new zealand customs
okay thanks thanks a lot bye
oh boy
the answer was we know nothing about
boxes
we have no idea where your boxes is so
it sounds like
the drama continues
this is uh
a [ __ ] storm as we say in the united
states
oh man
it's not on the plane yet
oh what else could go wrong
go faster guys you know
i got a schedule to keep
this because it has a chain hoist in
there you just throw that
the obligatory antarctic video
it's riveting
the physical demands in close quarters
in antarctica can result in elevated
levels of stress
it's not uncommon to experience a sense
of loneliness or disorientation
especially during the first few days or
even weeks that's it
i don't understand
the glove doesn't fit
this is because when people are walking
around at the south pole you have no
idea who it is you just see a big
a big red parker
now i have a question to ask you
did you have your vaccination before you
came down what kind of vaccination i've
got a lot of vaccinations
i've got everything you want no i had
nothing you had nothing no awesome guess
what i'm going to have them now you do
what if i tell you i had them now you're
not going to trust you'd have to see
proof
is the actual cdc closed distribution
center
and they allowed me to go in let's go up
close
a lot of other clothes
more
big reds
that's all you see when you're on the
ice big reds big reds big reds
car hearts these are nice because
they're
they're doubled inside they're warm and
so they have different clothes
for different purposes if you go to
mcmurdo versus if you go to south pole
versus hey
i never got any of these neat t-shirts
i wonder where you have to go to get
those
tomorrow morning
we're supposed to report at the cdc at 5
00 am
for flight at i don't know what time
we were being picked up here at 4 15
brutal
so that's the herc
c-130
for
propellers it's loud once it's turned on
you can't speak anymore at all
no communication for the next eight
hours you might also be really crammed
in the next eight hours we're going to
take a flight from christchurch new
zealand
all the way to mcmurdo and then normally
tomorrow if all goes well we'll take
another flight from mcmurdo station to
south pole right there
every year
we have to mark
the new location of the axis of rotation
because we are on this
large sheet of ice